Speaker 1: Let's just get right into things
today, because there is so much to cover,
one of the things I mentioned in my Monday
segment about the current Israeli-Palestinian
flare up is that not only does Hamas benefit
from what's going on because they justify
their existence by being on the receiving
end of Israeli rockets.
But Benjamin Netanyahu justifies his position
as prime minister, as Mr. Security, when there
are at this point, I believe it's 3500 Hamas
rockets that have been shot in the direction
of Israel.
And I even mentioned Benjamin Netanyahu likely
realizes that unless something changes, his
days as prime minister are numbered, unable
to form a government.
Recently, he was recently interviewed on CBS
Face the Nation by John Dickerson.
And Dickerson, to his credit, went right at
this idea and said essentially, are you killing
people to try to stay in power?
That's the crux of it.
Let's look at the exchange.
Speaker 2: Let me get
Speaker 3: before you know, neither Arabs
killing is is used for Jews killing Arabs,
Arabs and
Speaker 4: Jews.
Let me ask I want you to respond to one other
thing before we go, which is your domestic
challenges.
You are under investigation for bribery, fraud,
breach of trust.
You've also had some difficulty for failed
attempts to put together a government in the
last twenty three months.
This leads to the criticism that your current
actions are basically an effort to stay in
power.
And what's your response to that?
Speaker 3: That's preposterous.
You know, when I was a young soldier, 18 years
old, I heard a fellow soldier who died in
my arms.
A few years later, my brother, my older brother,
died while leading a rescue mission in Entebbe,
Uganda, to release Israeli hostages.
I've seen combatants fall.
I've seen my brother fall.
And I think anybody who knows me knows that
I've never, ever subordinated security concerns,
the life of our soldiers, the life of our
citizens for political interests.
That's just hogwash.
I'll do what I have to do to protect the lives
of Israeli citizens and to restore peace and
made peace with four Arab countries.
I'm glad that we have a restoration of some
considerable calm within Israel.
That's my goal, to restore peace and quiet
and to assure tranquility and reconciliation
for all.
Speaker 4: But this is a persistent criticism,
Mr. Prime Minister.
Why do you think it persists?
Speaker 3: It persists because I've been reelected
five times, it persists because I beat every
other candidate in the public polls and in
direct election simulations, apparently the
people of Israel, the majority, don't agree
with his false criticism.
The cynicism, they know that I'm standing
there for Israel and I'm doing everything
I can for the safety and prosperity of the
Israeli people.
By the way, all of Israel's citizens, Jews
and Arabs alike.
Speaker 4: All right, Mr. Prime Minister,
we're out of time.
Speaker 1: This is not idle speculation.
The Associated Press reports that, quote,
Just over a week ago, the long time Israeli
leaders political career seemed all but over.
He had failed to form a coalition government
following an indecisive parliamentary election,
and his political rivals were on the cusp
of pushing him out of office.
Now, as Israel and Gaza Hamas rulers wage
their fourth war in just over a decade, Netanyahu's
fortunes have changed dramatically.
His rival's prospects have crumbled.
Netanyahu is back in his comfortable role
as Mr. Security, and the country could soon
be headed for yet another election campaign
that would guarantee him at least several
more months in office.
Rightly, this is making many people ask, was
this another one of these disgusting, cynical
moves that we've come to expect from Benjamin
Netanyahu?
We saw this before during the lead up to an
election in Israel.
And exactly as I suggested, I suspected on
Monday, more people are now asking this exact
same question.
And there's every indication that this is
exactly what is going on.
Will it work?
I wish I could say no, but sadly it might.
And of course, the longer Netanyahu remains
in power as well as the longer Hamas remains
in power, the prospects of a real peace deal
are essentially zero, as I outlined earlier
this week.